[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today and
season Chicago hi Nancy welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello taking thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
no I want to know what you would suggest
a person would do after the U.S switches
to a digital currency
what should people do Who currently use
cash as a budgeting tool
um well the first thing is I'm going to
suggest you quit me reading so many
articles on the internet
because the US is not going to switch to
a hundred percent digital
that's that's the goal people that are
trying to sell gold
on Fox News commercials
that are telling you that
because there's not the US here's the
thing Nancy the U.S is about 95 digital
now
almost all of our transactions move a
digit from one account to another now if
you write a check it's a digit it's not
cash if you use a debit card it's a
digit not cash if you have direct
deposit from Social Security or direct
deposit from your work it's not cash
it's a digit those are all digital
transactions if you buy a house and you
wire money from your uh mutual fund to
your closing attorney it's a digit
almost if you buy a car these days I
bought a car that wired money to the
dealer it's a it's a digit I didn't walk
over there with a suitcase of cash and
so the vast majority of transactions
ninety something percent of them
probably not north of 95 percent in the
US are already digital but the is the US
going to do away with the Greenback and
not in my lifetime or yours
I sure hope you're right because I've
been
one person that can't have a credit card
because if I spend money just by swiping
it doesn't register with me and it'll
just evaporate now I'm a person that has
a redneck emergency fund in my front
pocket it's a thousand bucks and 100
bills I've carried it most of my life in
my wallet and so I'm with you I'm a cash
dude and I I'm not above walking up and
actually making somebody learn how to
make change for the first time at the
register all day and so um I'm that guy
so I'm right with you but I I truly
don't think we're going to do away with
currency and most of what you're reading
has a Fear Factor to get you to buy gold
or it is some kind of conspiracy theory
stuff on uh
bricks or any of these other things that
are going around just to make us worry
that the entire U.S economy is so
fragile that it's going to collapse
because Russia which isn't their economy
is hardly the size of Texas is is going
to do something Russia's not going to do
spit they don't have the muscle too they
can't even feed their own people and so
you know it just Nancy whatever it is
that you're reading that's causing you
to worry quit reading it
scary it is scary I you know I know
people have different
thoughts around all of that but then
there's parts of me that I think about
there's so many things that have
happened throughout history that we who
are used to those things we look at this
and go yeah it's just part of life but
as it was occurring people were probably
like oh my gosh this is crazy I mean
Cars the cars that we have today there
was a time where that wasn't a thing
flying airplanes like all those things
you could look back and go oh my gosh
there was a time when this wasn't a
thing and maybe who knows and the next
lifetime the Next Generation they will
live in a different sort of currency but
we already have we already are I mean
you think about when I was a kid we the
number of checks we wrote yeah you don't
do that anymore I I the number of times
you write you see someone write a check
at the grocery store yeah yeah today I
don't do they even take you're much more
likely still using cash yeah but my
point is we've adapted and that's that
stuff is a slow burn and before you know
it you look up and you go oh yeah we
live lives our lives in a totally
different way
um yeah I just think there's some baby
stuff for the innocent version the the
malevolent version uh the the
level I can't say the evil version is
that there's a conspiracy that the U.S
is going to control the all the digits
and therefore they're going to control
your life well they already do
have all the digits yeah and they don't
control your life with those digits and
so so the question is not the digits
being allowed to control your life
digital money because when you use your
Apple phone or when you use a car a
credit card or a debit card or you
transfer money any other way uh ACH or
anything else it's all digits so when
you do that they already have all of
that that's all available and so and so
far they've not used that to steal our
freedoms no no but there's a commercial
I heard it the other day and then I saw
a different thing a write-up that you
know when the US goes digital you are
not going to do transactions and if they
want to cancel you because they don't
like your faith or they don't like
whatever they can just turn off your
ability to do business as if it's like
the the mark of the beast or something
in Revelation okay and it's just I'm
sorry folks I you know
this there may be a mark of the beast
someday but this one's not it there was
a whole thing going around for years
that the credit card was the mark of the
beach oh yeah you had to have a credit
card to do a transaction and then the
last one was with the factory quarantine
yeah they had the uh the the uh vaccine
passport yes that was going to be the
mark of the beast and at one point it
was when you're but I'm getting older
when your iPhone scans your face to let
you into the phone it's like they're
gonna scan your eyeball yeah and that's
gonna be yeah now they got your eyeball
so I mean it's it's ever and just don't
get Rachel Nancy I'm glad you didn't
call When Rachel Cruz was here because
she's the conspiracy theorist
extraordinaire and um she would have
joined you in this but no we're I'm not
going to join you so I I'm gonna tell
you honey don't worry I'm not worried
I'm not worried I got big old piles of
cash and I'm not worried about it going
out of style
um like real actual greenbacks so there
we go
yeah you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be fine and uh and gold doesn't solve
this by the way because there's never
been a failed economy or a government
takeover when people exchanged gold bars
I'm gonna run down to Walmart with my
gold bar
since the economy failed and I'm gonna
get me some blue jeans
it's just not gonna happen boys and
girls not gonna happen Okay you can't
find a since the Roman Empire
a modern day economy in the last 400 300
years that used actual gold as a medium
of exchange exclusively so these guys
telling you to buy gold because that's
what one of the commercials was on the
digits yeah because Americans are going
digital and you need gold
it's the latest fear to buy gold crap
don't do it